mexico is once again in the
final instances of the gold cup but
let's review the triumphs of the
mexican team in this competition the
first victories happened in the
years 1965 1971 1977 and 1993 but this
is not all I invite you to come with me to
see  a summary of the trajectory of
the mexico gold cup championships in
addition to those mentioned mexico would
become champion in 1996 with
nine teams participating in this
edition with its scorer cuauhtémoc
blanco then mexico would
win the championship again in 1998 this time
with 10 teams in the competition with his
figure
luís hernández scoring the winning goal
in 2003 mexico would obtain its
title playing in the final against
brazil as it happened in 1996 after
eliminating jamaica
this seventh title would come thanks to the
annotation of daniel osorno  in the
2009 gold cup edition mexico managed to
win the title after beating the
usa with a 5-0 win while
that in 2011 mexico achieved its
two-time championship defeating the usa 4 to 2 for the
second time in a row
javier 'el chicharito' hernández finished
as the tournament's top scorer in 2015
mexico achieved another championship with goals
from andrés guardado este capi o corona and
oribe peralta after  a
defensive error by jamaica the
final score was 3 to 1 however
mexico managed to obtain the most
recent gold cup title in 2019
after beating archrival usa
1-0 with a goal by jonathan dos santos but the
question of  million will mexico
become champion of the gold cup for the
twelfth time we will know on sunday the
first of august from here las vegas'
inside the stadium the leader reported for
him gives us or in spanish
natalia lanzelotti